meanwhile president trump is urging his  supporters to not repeat what we saw  last wednesday on capitol hill today the  white house released a statement from  the president urging  no violence this comes as the military  and police prepare for next week's  inauguration  armed national guard troops are now in  place inside the u.s capitol  as lawmakers move forward with the  impeachment proceedings today  this all comes as other congressional  members have been briefed on security  threats ahead of the inauguration  and the security threat is not just in  the capitol the fbi warns of possible  armed protests at state capitals  nationwide  so national guard troops have been  activated in several states